president biden knew what was coming and
let it happen anyway the embattled
president addressing the nation again on
what went wrong in afghanistan after a
bombshell report proves his team was
warned u.s diplomats in afghanistan told
the administration last month that the
country was on the verge of a rapid and
catastrophic takeover by the taliban
here's what the president had to say
the united states stands by its
commitment that we've made these people
and includes other vulnerable afghans
such as women leaders and journalists
we are particularly focused on our
engagements on making sure every
american
who wants to leave can get to the
airport i have seen no question of our
credibility from our allies around the
world this is about america leading the
world
and all our allies have agreed with that
we've made an agreement with the with
the taliban thus far they've allowed
them to go through it's and they're
interested to go through
so we know of no circumstance where
american citizens are carrying an
american passport are trying to get
through to the airport let's put this
thing in perspective here
what interest do we have in afghanistan
at this point with al-qaeda gone
biden saying several times in that
speech that there were no issues between
the taliban and americans getting to the
airport
there are really disturbing reports that
american defense secretary lloyd austin
said on a call that americans are in
fact being beaten
beaten by the taliban while trying to
reach the kabul airport the pentagon
asked about this just moments ago
the reports americans have been beaten
by the taliban in kabul
is the u.s military under orders to stay
at the airport and not go protect them i
think we've been talking about this
throughout the entire briefing we're
certainly mindful of these reports and
they're deeply troubling and we have
communicated to the taliban that
that's absolutely unacceptable that we
want free
passage through their checkpoints for
documented americans and by and large
that's happening
shannon
they say
that there are reports of americans
being beaten by the taliban and they're
troubled by it and then the president
says
everything's fine if you want to go to
the airport i haven't heard anything i
know it's it's how do we as normal
average people know more about this than
the president does or is he being
disingenuous because to say that there
are no americans having trouble getting
to the airport we all probably know
people that are trying to get out we're
all probably trying to help people i
know some personally and there was a guy
in the new york post yesterday who said
he's an american he said he took his
passport his three-year-old and went to
the airport on wednesday was 10 feet
away from the u.s marine and could not
get passage into the airport these are
not you know things that are not
happening these are people putting their
names in their faces to them these are
public reports i don't understand how
our president doesn't know about that or
his team isn't telling him about that
where the breakdown is but there's
definitely a breakdown there our own
benjamin hall steve harrigan many of our
reporters who have been on the ground
there for months since last fall have
been warning about this exact thing and
steve harrigan said today everyone he
knows on the ground and if you've been
there on the ground knows the reality of
what's happening how does the
commander-in-chief not know so we don't
know greg if the commander-in-chief is
lying
or is confused
there's no way to tell look you know
what he did he checked waze
he saw he was like how long does it take
to get to the airport oh it's 30 minutes
everything's great and the taliban does
not show up on waze or the gps it is
amazing how bad
he has screwed this up when you consider
that this was a popular decision think
about that seven let's say 75 percent i
think of the population wanted to get
out so
75
of the population could have made this
decision all you had to do was get the
exit right and you ended the longest war
ever you would be a hero but poor joe
couldn't do it instead he pretends the
argument is over the decision to pull
out not the horrible conduct associated
with the pull out so what you what you
end up learning is that he beyond the
decision he brought nothing absolutely
nothing to the table that's frightening
we knew that this is when i smeared the
uh when i when i slammed the media uh
they enabled and protected him
uh as as well as his snotty elitist
untested uh ivy league candy asses he's
surrounded by but most important they
buried the laptop story so this guy
could get in so taliban should be
thanking jeff zucker jeff bezos the view
everybody else who wanted that story
uncovered or yeah uncovered is a good
story or is it covered never mind the
whole thing is weird
the whole thing is weird because no one
answers the one big question we all know
what it is why the taliban why the
taliban why them there was no other
alternative over 20 years while we were
there clearly this is owned the only
choice so they just were like hey we're
the only choice we're just going to wait
you guys out isn't it almost comical
that a country this beloved and this
desired just handed over the country to
70 000 mountain hillbillies with cell
phones
what does that tell you what does that
tell you since the 90s we made no
progress
no progress in creating an alternative
to the taliban it's mind-boggling and
then obama lets their leader out so now
he's in charge i don't know man it's
it's
what we witnessed was a controlled
surrender to 70 000 people we killed
more than 70 000 people with isis
that's right and they have more than
cell phones now degan they have humvees
they have drones they have blackhawks
they have night vision goggles they have
billions in u.s military right i was
going to go through i have it on my
phone the list of the the flood of
weapons that has fallen into the
taliban's hands
greg before i move on the progress has
been our counterterrorism operation
combat operations ended in 2014
and the counter-terrorism is denying a
haven to al-qaeda and not only we not
had a major terror attack on u.s soil we
also hadn't had a casualty in
afghanistan for about a year and a half
and to quote jennifer griffin the
incomparable jennifer griffin she said
we were in in afghanistan to stop
partners um you know to stop terrorism
from brewing from growing and our
partners have now been abandoned they're
in hiding they've disappeared we don't
have eyes and ears on the ground and
this we'll talk about later this over
the horizon capability is laughable i
will go into it in the next block but
we're going to be flying drones that by
the time they get to afghanistan from
the persian gulf have
very little time to actually
do any work
but
i keep hearing this word humiliating
that this has been a humiliating week
no
not for americans not for our service
members those who served and sacrificed
those who are there those who are going
into afghanistan now
it is infuriating and frightening every
american listening to this garbage from
this garbage president has every right
to be pissed off
the only humiliating thing is for the
only humiliation is on joe biden and the
people who work for joe biden in the
white house in his administration fellow
democrats should be humiliated and of
course to your point all the media
grifters
and the hucksters and the swindlers who
sold this broken bobblehead to the
american people not only is he's a liar
but maybe he's delusional he's inept and
he's a cipher and he's our
commander-in-chief and that's why we're
suffering through this right now richard
listen uh i'm humiliated but i'm not
humiliated just to joe i'm humiliated at
every president that got us to this
particular point it started with george
bush and this mission to go get osama
bin laden that's why we started in
afghanistan then it turned into oh we're
going to build a democracy which clearly
the people of afghanistan did not want
so here we are 20 years later with a
botched exit and when this war started
just for context i was a freshman in
high school right i had classmates
people in my high school that went to
fight in afghanistan
right thinking that they were there to
stop the terrorists now here we are 20
years later we've had members of
congress year after year after year vote
for a budget approving more money to
afghanistan more money to afghanistan
forces for what to what avail to what
point
right because this is where we are where
we are now is the taliban is in control
and guess what there are at least three
presidents that knew that the taliban
was stronger than the afghan government
the obama administration do because they
were negotiating with them the trump
administration knew because they were
negotiating with them and they'll and
the biden administration knew because
they are currently in negotiations with
the taliban so the afghan government was
a fail from the beginning and this is
frustrating for somebody who saw this
war start when i was a teenager and
didn't get a chance to actually have my
say in a presidential election until
2008. some of my classmates didn't get
the same right and they went to go fight
in this but but you have to keep two
things separate one is that going
absolutely going to war was was a
decision based on what happened to us we
didn't start anything absolutely yeah
but but but it i think both of these
things could be right that we reduce the
threat of terror
but they want television they don't want
us there no they don't want us there so
it's time to go but that's not even the
debate the debate is how we went right
and you know i think i will say this i
think it's monday morning quarterbacking
to think that whoever whichever
president was with charged with getting
us out couldn't have made it could have
made it any better there was no telling
what going on which are going on
they couldn't have gone worse of course
it could of course i couldn't have gone
of course i couldn't have done it but
there's no talent needs to own there's
no oh oh
i absolutely
[Applause]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else